See, I'm going to see your
[Silence]
Alhamdulillah.
I have a question to ask.
If a person
or let me reframe the question,
a Muslim
is a Muslim
required
or a Muslim that follows the teachings
of the Quran and the teachings of the
Sunnah.
Is the Muslim
ever in danger
of missing out on the dunya?
We have some head shakers over here,
right? You know, I just I was yesterday
years old when I found out that I always
thought your name was Hanife. It's
actually with an S, right? Hanice.
My mistake. So Hanise, you learn
something new every day. So
will a person miss out on any any of the
dunya if they adhere to the Quran and
Sunnah? You say no. No, no, yes.
No. You see, when you answer a question
this, what we're trying to do is
we're trying to build a muscle in your
mind, before you ever answer a question
that, any question that,
always say,
"What did Allah tell me about this?"
"What did the prophet tell me about
this?" I should be able to ask you
immediately, "What's your evidence?"
Never allow yourself to answer a
question that before you have the
evidence clear in your mind first. And
I'll tell you why
it is so important that before you say
something,
you are sure that it is correct. Of
course, here this is a simulation.
You're not going to go forth and and and
and give fatwa to the world. Here we are
practicing right and that's one of the
ways that the prophet sallallah.aii
wasallam would teach the companions. He
would ask them they would guess they
would have educated guesses and then he
would correct them. It's a method of
teaching but the reason for this is that
there are three paths to the heart.
This is very interesting.
Allah mentions three paths to the heart.
One path
is sight.
Another path is what you hear.
And the third path
is what you say.
Strange, right? What do you mean what I
say? That's what's going out. You know
why that is? Why that's considered a
path to the heart? Because once you say
something,
you have now committed to something. You
have now set in motion the process to
changing those words into belief. Even
if it's a lie, even if a person knows
that it's a lie when they say it, if
they say it enough, it will eventually
be something that they believe.
[Silence]
and so Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala tells
us that the people of the book some of
them
they commit
atrocities
and then they say to themselves
anyways if Allah punishes us it's only
going to be a for a few days we'll just
push through it you know bite down bite
the bullet right and then we can have
our cake and eat it
and Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala says
they have been deluded
by their own lies
meaning that they told this lie so much
that they started to believe it
themselves.
When a person says something, it becomes
twice as hard
to later change that
to the point that some have said
it is easier to fool a people than it is
that to convince them that they've been
fooled.
It is far easier
to
fool someone than it is to convince
someone that they've been fooled. That
is very difficult because now we've got
other things in the process here.
If you ever watch some very skilled
police interrogations,
one of the things that they do is they
never let the suspect that they are
interrogating double down on his lie.
They don't let him finish the sentence.
Were you there? I was not. Come on now.
They won't let him finish. Why? because
once he finishes it, he will start to
believe it and then it will be
undetectable as a lie anymore.
When a person speaks something, this
becomes one of the paths to the heart.
And Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala says about
the
that those three paths to their hearts
have been sealed. Their sight, their
hearing, and they speak no good. And so
the the all the pathways to the heart
have been sealed off by their
disobedience of Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala. Back to the original question.
If a person follows the Quran and
Sunnah, will they miss out on the duny?
So, everyone here said no except for
this guy. Yes. I call him,
right? Okay. Yes. The guy with the hair.
Tell me why. What's your evidence? many
describes.
[Arabic recitation]
[Silence]
hadith the prophet sallall.aii alaihi
wasallam tells us
four traits.
If you have these four traits,
don't worry about what you are going to
miss out on of the dunya.
Meaning these traits are going to impede
your acquiring or experiencing of some
of the dunya. But the dunya that passes
you by
because of these traits is not worth
having. It's not worth having. You will
you have to make a choice. You will
arrive at a crossroads where there's a
fork in the road. You will choose either
this or this. But you can't have both at
the same time simultaneously.
And so that is why many of the
companions
the scholars they refer to the and the's
relationship with each other as what
anyone remember
what do they call them the and theat
what is dat
is co-wives
a man who has two wives
You make one happy, the other one's
going to be upset with you. You make the
other one happy, first one's going to be
upset with you.
You will not be able to make them both
satisfied equally 100%. Just don't even
it's not possible.
You will always please one at the
expense of the other.
That is why they referred to them as
co-wives.
the and the you have to choose. Not
always.
Not always. And not in a way that will
that will jeopardize
your existence. Not in a way that
will jeopardize your life, but in a way
that will put you to the test. Because
at the end of the day, that is the
nature of the test.
[Silence]
You have to choose which one is going to
be primary And which one is going to be
secondary?
You have to make that choice.
You have to make the choice to either
see the dunya from the lens of the
hereafter or to see the hereafter from
the lens of the dunya. If you see the
hereafter from the lens of the dunya,
you will look at it as those nations
before us that were doomed.
[Silence]
And so if If you look at the through the
lens of the
you will look at it as inshallah it'll
work itself out you know but I need to
get this right now I need to have ex I
need to know exactly how much is in my
account right now I need to know exactly
this minute I need to know everything
about the duny in detail and the
[Arabic recitation]
out
inshallah it's going to work itself out.
I mean, how bad could it be, right? At
the end of the day, as long as you're a
Muslim, even if you go to hell for a
little bit, you'll be okay. You'll get
out eventually. So, it'll work itself
out. That's the attitude of those who
look at the through the lens of the
dunya.
Then there are those who look at the
through the lens of the
every time they stand to make a
decision.
The first question to the in their mind
is
what am I going to say to Allah when he
asks me about this? Not in general
specifically this thing right here. What
am I going to say? What's my answer?
[Silence]
He was a contemporary of Islam. As a
matter of fact, when she Islam was
exiled to Egypt,
He's a great muadith and they're from
Egypt.
When she Islam came and you know people
came around this big scholar and they're
all asking him and all these scholars
come out of the woodworks to come and
introduce themselves and
didn't say a single thing. He watched
the whole thing but he didn't say
anything. And so his students asked him
why didn't you say something? Why didn't
you speak? He said he likes to talk and
I to stay quiet. That's why
said
I have never said anything
nor have I ever done anything without
first preparing the answer that I'm
going to give to Allah for doing it for
saying it. I know it sounds a crazy
notion in our time right? How much of
what we actually do gets put through
that filter? How much of what we say we
actually think about before we say it?
Honestly,
look at our culture today.
The age of Twitter and Instagram and
imagine imagine how much we say without
ever thinking about it. As a matter of
fact, we don't even remember we said it.
It just it's not even something we
imagine. We don't even think about it.
The companions were narrated
one of the great students of Abbass.
He said that the companions he met, you
could ask them at the end of the week
every single thing that they have said
throughout the entire week and they
remember it verbatim.
Why?
Huh? because they knew exactly what
they're saying. They think about it a
hundred times before it comes out.
They don't let their tongue and lips
move without thinking. What are you
going to say to Allah when you meet him?
Now, if you give this much attention to
the hereafter, is your dunya going to
suffer somewhat? It has to. You don't
have two hearts in your chest.
You can't. You have to give your heart
to one. Either the dunya or the
hereafter. They're co-wives. You have to
give them to one. One heart goes to one
of them. Which one is it? It doesn't
mean that, you know, as some people will
say, she you know, these words that you
say, they're so dangerous. Why are they
dangerous? Because people will
misunderstand and they'll start to think
that Islam is all about just being in
the masid. and they'll leave the dunya
to fall apart. Are we suffering from
that right now? Tell me, are we in
danger of that happening right now?
Is there any danger in that? Come here
for let's see who is sitting in the in
the masjid and is saying hey you told me
to focus on the so my is just burning
down. Where are these people?
Once you provide this as a real life
example and this becomes a real hazard.
Sure.
But the Quran doesn't address things
that we already are driven to by nature.
It addresses things that we have to
discipline ourselves to do. how
many verses of the Quran talk about
taking care of your children? Like
explicitly, not generally, explicitly.
How many verses of the Quran
speak specifically about taking care of
your children? Very few. A handful. You
could count them on one hand.
How many verses speak about taking care
of your parents?
Dozens, if not more.
Why is that?
Because naturally human beings are
driven to take care of their children
naturally. They don't need anyone to
encourage that. Maybe at one verse here
or there and that's enough. They've
already got that under control.
What is not natural is taking care of
your parents. That's unnatural. That's a
discipline. You have to learn that. The
human being has to learn gratitude.
The same thing. How many human beings
are in danger
of foregoing their dunya? Very few.
And that's why the verses in the Quran
warning us to not forego our dunya are
very few because we're naturally driven
to the dunya. What we are not naturally
driven to is the the hereafter. That's
why we have to keep be be reminded
constantly to keep our eye on the goal,
keep our eye on the prize, keep our
focus on the hereafter, keep our f our
focus and our specific
plans on the
we'll end with this. When we speak about
the being primary, the being derivative
or conversely the being primary and the
dunya being derivative. What does that
mean?
I'll tell you what that means.
What that means is that if you are
focused, if you want to test yourself to
see
how am I seeing the duny and the look at
your plans for both places. Every one of
us here has plans for both places.
Right? I have plans for the dunya, for
myself, for my kids, for my family, for
whatever. And I have plans for the
hereafter. Everyone here does.
Look to see the nature of those plans.
If your plan for the hereafter is
general
and your plan for the dunya is specific
and detailed,
you've got the you've got the cart in
front of the horse.
However, if you look and see that your
plan for the hereafter is detailed
and your plan for the dunya is general,
that is how we have been commanded to
see this life and the next. What does
that mean? If you ask most people, where
do you want to go when you die? Everyone
will say, what?
Huh? Jenna. Without a doubt, immediately
I say, okay, what's your plan to get
there? How are you doing that exactly?
Inshallah, I'm trying my best. Okay.
What's your plan for the next five
years? Oh, I'm going to college. I'm
going this. I've got some money. I've
diversified my, you know, my portfolio
and I've got this, you know, , PL.
Everything is details.
But the is what inshallah it's going to
work itself out. I'll just keep throwing
things at the wall and something will
stick eventually or you'll get one big
your
grandiose plan where you're going to
have
your hand at the final moment.
best of people at that
it's going to make everything
we all tell ourselves
right that's
right at the end
right just like
going to march into
and I'm going to march into it. And for
that one thing, God will forgive all
that past. Marshall,
fantastic. Anyone here can guarantee
that? Exactly. Cuz I'll be the first to
ask you how and sign up as your
follower. If you can guarantee that, you
know how most of us are going to die,
especially in this country. a very
mundane routine,
boring, more boring than watching paint
dry. That's the
amount that you know, most people
statistically are going to die exactly
in that way. It's not going to be
fantastic. You're not going to go out in
flames. It's going to be very mundane.
One day is going to bleed into a million
other days
until we're either claimed by dementia
or claimed by, you know, our body
rotting on our bones, whatever it is.
That's not how you get to Jenna. You get
to Jenna by having a detailed plan.
Imagine if I had that same attitude with
the dunya. I'm going to Phoenix. Okay,
how you going to get there? Inshallah,
it'll work out. Come on. You know, Allah
has a plan for me. I'm sure I'll see a
sign on my way. I'm going to just I'm
going to drive wherever my heart and you
know what? At the end of the day,
Phoenix is big and I'll just make it
there. Is that a good plan?
Will I most likely make it to Phoenix?
And that's right next door. We're
talking about agenda
decades from now,
right?
You have to have a detailed plan. A
detailed plan. There are eight gates to
paradise. Which one have you which which
basket have you put your eggs in? Which
one are you going through?
And do you miss an opportunity to take
another step towards that gate? If
you're just if you if you're just
leaving it to the wind, very strong
chance you're not going to make it there
unscathed.
You will not.
You don't accidentally
stumble into paradise. You have to go
there.
You have to choose to go there. Make a
decision and a plan and follow that
detailed map.
And so
in closing, you have to make your
choice. You're either going to give the
details to the hereafter and the general
to the dunya, or you're going to give
the details to the dunya and the general
to the hereafter. But you cannot do
both. If you could do both, the
companions would have done that before
you.
The companions would have done that
before you. They were stronger than we
are. They were more resilient.
They were more clever. They were braver
than we are. They had standards higher
than ours. It's not shameful. Those are
our ancestors. We take all pride in our
in our predecessors.
and
subhanahu
Subhan Allah.
Subhanahu
Wasam.